TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is an
introduction to Brillo.
Our vision with Brillo is to
bring the simplicity and speed
of software
development to hardware
by joining together
three major components--
an embedded OS based on
Android, core services that
enable a great
getting-started experience
and allow you to
operate at scale,
and a developer kit with tools
to build, test, and debug
your solution.
Let's examine each area
in a little more detail.
First, let's talk about
the operating system
and the hardware that runs it.
It's based on Android
and it's open source,
so anybody can review the code.
It's updated regularly on
two schedules, every six
weeks for minor updates,
and every six months
for long-term support,
or LTS, updates.
Brillo builds from source,
with a board support
package that adapts Brillo
to a particular board.
Now, you shouldn't
need to muck with this.
But it's there if you
really want to dive
in with some custom stuff.
ARM, Intel, and
MIPS architectures
are supported,
with configurations
as small as 128
megabytes of storage
and 32 megabytes of RAM.
We recommend a featured
Brillo-compatible board
to get started.
Now, these boards are
all verified and tested
to work well with Brillo,
able to run the latest
version of Brillo, and
supported with documentation,
including code labs.
This helps to provide a
consistent development
experience, and helps your
product stay up to date.
Next, let's look at the core
services and the developer
console.
Brillo works
seamlessly with Weave,
which makes it easy
for users to get
your device on the network
with a secure and consistent
set-up experience.
It lets your users
interact with their devices
through their mobile
phone or desktop,
allows your device to work
with Weave-enabled apps,
and the Weave
protocol can extend
to support a wide range
of connected devices.
Brillo helps you collect
and aggregate usage data
from your devices in the field
with your user's permission.
You can then view and analyze
this data in the Weave
developer console to
understand end user
behavior and validate product
requirements and assumptions.
For Brillo devices, crash
statistics and debug data
can also be collected
from devices in the field
and used to improve the
reliability of your products,
again, with your
user's permission.
Also for Brillo devices,
once a new build is uploaded,
you can then apply it to some
or all the devices in the field.
One last thing,
the developer kit.
The BDK is based on the
Android.mk build architecture
and runs on Ubuntu 14.04.
It allows you to perform
incremental builds
or build the entire
product from source.
Testing techniques
available include
local unit tests, individual
integration tests, or even
the ability to use your
own continuous build
and integration
testing infrastructure.
And you can also use
the familiar adb tool
over ethernet or USB to
test, inspect, and update
your target device without
any special equipment.
Now that you have a high-level
understanding of Brillo,
why not dive in a little deeper
with this link, also included
in the description below?
Oh, and please give us
feedback so that together, we
can make Brillo the
perfect solution
for your next big thing.